ابدا معك وائل نذكر بالذي جرى خلال الساعه
الاخيره واستهداف شقه سكنيه في حي النصر
وما قالته حركه الجهات
بالتاكيد فدا الذي حصل هو استهداف شقه
سكنيه في بنايه سكنيه ربما تشاهدونها عن
بعد هي
الكائنه في الطوابق العليا الطابق قبل
الاخير تقريبا هو الذي استهدف ولكن استهدف
باسلحه ربما قنابل كالتي كانت تستخدم
سابقا وهي الجي بي يو 39 وربما قنابل ذكيه
جديده ربما هناك تغيير ما في الاستهداف
لكن هو من مشاهدنا الاوليه يعتبر
استهدافا متكررا وسيناريو يكون متكرر في
عمليات الاغتيال الخمس الاخيره استهدفت
هذه الشقه لكن الطوابق الثلاث العليا
تضررت تضررا كبيرا
بحيث حولتهم الى دمار ولم يعودوا بالامكان
استخدامه من قبل ذويهم فضلا بطبي عن
الاضرار التي لحقت بعدد من الشقق السكنيه
في ذات البنايه او في المباني المجاوره
الاهم في هذا السياق هو ان الموضوع يتعلق
بعمليه اغتيال منظمه ومدبره تقوم بها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتوج بها سلسله
الاغتيالات التي
نفذتها حتى هذا الان وبالتاكيد بداتها
بالقاده الكبار الثلاثه لسرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
الحديث يدور بطبيعه الحال حسب مشاهداتنا
الاولى وحسب روايه رجال الدفاع المدني
والاسعاف وغيرهم بالتاكيد الموضوع الحديث
يدور عن دمار في الشقه اشتعال للنيران
بداخلها وهذا يعني بان اسرائيل ربما تكون
قد استخدمت اكثر من تقنيه لاولا لتحدث
اصابه مباشره ثانيا
الاحداث قتل المباشر ثالثا لاحداث حرائق
شديده في المكان حتى تضمن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان احدا بداخل الشقه لا يستطيع
ولا يتمكن من الفرار او الافلات من واحده
من هذه من الوسائل الثلاث لعمليات القتل
دمار اصابه مباشره ومن ثم اشعال للحريق
وبالتالي قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تكون
امعانا في عمليه القتل حتى تضمن عمليه
النتيجه كما يقولون هناك بطبيعه الحال
حقيقه يعني اسماء تتردد
بشكل منذ فتره منذ بدايه عمليه الاغتيال
لشهيدين حسب ما شاهدنا نحن عندما وصلنا
طواقم الدفاع المدني تمكنت من اخلاء جثتين
من داخل هذه
البنايه ومن داخل هذه الشقه السكنيه بعد
صعوبه حقيقه في عمليه الدخول والاقتحام
والسيطره على الحريق والدخان المنبعث بسبب
هذه الحرائق والركام الموجود وعمليه البحث
في ظل هذه الظروف في ظل امكانيات متواضعه
بارادتهم حقيقه وبعزيمتهم يدخلون ويغامرون
حتى يصلوا وبالفعل تمكنوا من اخلاع بعد
جهد جهيد تمكنوا من اخلاء جثتين ونحن
راينا ايضا اصابه اخرى لكن على وجه
التاكيد هناك شهيدين وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه هي الاخرى تحدثت عن شهيدين
وخمسه جرحى بطبيعه الحال وكان من يعني كان
لدينا اسماء كثيره تتردد حقيقه اكثر من
اسمين وصلت الينا وردت بانهم المستهدفين
من وراء عمليه الاغتيال لكن كما جرت
العاده بالنسبه لنا نحن نتريف وحتى يتم
الاعلان بشكل رسمي اما وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه واما من الجهات المختصه
المعنيه
بالافصاح عن الاسماء لان الامر يتعلق
بعمليه اغتيال وليس بمجرد مواطنين عاديين
وفي مثل عمليات الاغتيال تكررت كثيرا فدى
بانه يتردد اسماء واشاعات وروايات وخلاف
ولكن في نهايه المطاف يتضح بان كثير من
الروايات اساسا هي روايات مفبركه وروايات
غير حقيقيه وان المقصود من الاغتيال يكون
اسم اخر مختلف ولذلك
في هذه المعلومات